you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing a
fifteen Oh game actually check that this
is a fifteen to against master XXL our
first time playing let's go with d6
let's see what we get open Sicilian
Knight our queen I don't know if I
really have a good system against Queen
takes could bring the knight out and
getting a tempo against the Queen but
there's usually that Bishop b5 follow up
and white is prepared to give up the
bishop for night anyhow we don't go down
that road open Sicilian land let's head
for Knight ourf and see what white
throws at us with this move 6 a big
moment in the game many different
options for white Bishop e3 Bishop g5 h3
Bishop e2 f4 Bishop g5 it is ok well
we go at the e6 here yeah let's go with
e6 form a small pond Center if Bishop
III or Bishop e2 was played I would give
some consideration to e5 but now that
the bishop is putting pressure on my
knight I really don't want a weakened d5
so Queen to d2 okay I guess white is
preparing queenside castle
I'm not sure the move order details here
I'm kind of just tossing around Bishop
e7 Knight d7 Queen c7 and b5 which one
of those should I go with I don't think
I want to give black the option to
damage my structure if I play Queen c7
maybe they go in for the bishop for
Knight exchange excuse me so I'm leaning
more towards Bishop e7 that seems pretty
universal and good you know he doesn't
have so many options anyhow so let's
make the move first we know we're gonna
have to make hmm okay it's interesting
quite sure what the idea is okay maybe
I'm sure g4 expansion
I'm pretty sure white is going to go
queenside so let's see probably Queen c7
here yeah let's go with Queen c7 or
yeah I'll go with Queen c7 for a moment
I'm thinking that a knight might jump in
here and have something against this
square and get after a bishop if the
bishop takes my knight I have to be a
bit cautious of how I recapture in some
cases because of a night landing on b5
with then a follow up of going into d6
with check so I'm leaning towards 97
connecting knights preparing to meet
Bishop takes Knight with Knight takes
and I believe from there I'm gonna look
to play b5 yeah I think I could get this
move in let's do this
they're always these tactical ideas that
White has with jumping this night into
f5 or maybe this move first
something revolving around these two
squares especially d5 because if the
knight is able to get there and I'm not
able to capture him immediately with a
pawn or a knight
he's hitting with tempo okay am I gonna
run into some problems if I play b5 I
think what white could go in for our
variation where they give up a night and
get three pawns if I play b5 so I'm
wondering if I should first prep this
with rook b8 and only then b5 to be a
bit careful because I'm
an f6 is soon to not be stable after
this bishop moves g5 and he has to find
a new home
maybe if rook b8 is fine on a bishop
move I could think about 90s Knight e5
in to c4 I don't think I want to allow a
sacrifice on b5 and then you know
grabbing three pawns for the minor piece
you know not really so so much of a fan
of that um not sure if it's right
I already chewed up a ton of time here
in a game that is likely to turn very
sharp I'm not going to be castling on
the same side as white that's for sure
after this last move and this is one of
those interesting positions where I
don't know that at my king stands
hmm I don't know that he's any safer
castled than he is on eh at the moment I
should also mention that this move rands
from my mind but I believe light would
follow up with Bishop takes Knight and
then bypassed my H pawn and then even go
one further with g6 and successfully
undermined this structure I cannot allow
that to happen as that weakens the
center the d5 square ultimately okay so
they're going with h4 um should I move
my knight now or play b5 maybe b5 isn't
a bad idea
let's see b5 within maybe Knight b6 into
here or 95 into there I think I'm gonna
go with the b5 yeah let's do it
this was pretty much my intention so if
it's the wrong idea it's the wrong idea
but you know I played rook b8 with this
intent with this follow up idea so I
might as well just swing the back
completely around maybe I could put this
rook on b8 to use actually linked what a
knight on c4 after its capture this
would open up the B file and I'm
thinking it should maybe go straight in
for that 95 or Knight b6 into c4 however
up the - I think I like the more central
post it's more forward it's in the
center and it actually is within
checking distance I could maybe take
this piece out if I need to it's
important to know I am prepared to let's
say sacrifice my rook if they do some
sacrifice here although I don't think
that that's going to be the case now
because this last move Bishop e3 Bishop
d3 is masking White's major pieces from
seeing d6
so let's see what but
stur double XL is coming up with
certainly have a tsunami of ponds here
creeping closer towards my king who is
not yet committed we have a loose piece
on d4 this is these are in sharp
positions things we want to take note of
might be a very useful tempo against
this guy
queen c5 although I think Bishop III
would be a fine reply
sometimes if the king was castled over
here you might see a peace sacrifice
on g4 especially if it hits on a bishop
that's on e3 after the smoke clears
at any moment I could play b4 notice if
this poem is on a3 this would help open
up the kingside so now as mentioned I
have to be prepared to go elsewhere with
my night I don't think this is such a
bad I think g5 Knight h5 I'm fine so I
could get one of the bishops pretty much
if I want to go for that I don't want to
take this LightScribe bishop he's I
don't know a dummy I think I just want
to go to Knight c4 and I think they take
my night out because he's the more
valuable of their two bishops and in
that position I think I capture with the
pawn
just to get some play on the B file oh
let's go with that you know maybe I even
have an option with my knight on f6 when
challenged my play to d7 or play to h5
it's a big decision if I go towards h5
I'm really looking to halt White's
progress against my king halt White's
progress with expanding on the Kings
side so I'm surprised actually a bit
surprised that there is a think here so
I guess they're still weighing whether
or not okay I thought they would have to
do that
and I think this really makes a lot of
sense to open up the B file
because now moves like queen bee seven
Queen b6
just another heavy piece on the beef
file is immediately throwing a strike at
b2 which is not the easiest pond to
defend
or over this bishop couldn't spring
right to life with a d5 push hmm let me
get to the more ow more direct stuff
suppose g5 where am I going with my
knight
want to go in to age five I don't like
this idea of g5 night here and then as I
was mentioning earlier these these
tricks of maybe Knight f5 Knight d5 I
think I could rely upon this Knights
post on H five give him some support
white no longer has that light square
bishop and sometimes this would be a
concern g5 Knight h5 a bishop can be
disruptive to a knight on age five so I
think I wouldn't I don't think I would
mind devoting one piece over here as
defense for my king maybe what white is
considering his first age five so that
on g5 I no longer have this square so
these are the two moves that I'm
guessing white is considering right here
but you know what seven there tension
clearly has to be on the b2 square of
course okay they're going straight in
for g5 hmm
yeah I really don't see what kind of
good squares mine it'll have soon a
fives gonna be taken away I go Knight d7
hmm okay night age five don't have very
many options huh let's go with it I
don't think I'll be able to work out
which one is really better I think it is
it's my intuitive feel tells me it's
night age five so now there's already a
pretty serious threat Queen B seven I
could have maybe considered that on that
last move but okay Queen are they not
going to do anything about Queen B seven
how did defend B - Queen B seven Knight
a for Bishop d7 they have to play b3
there's no way that that could I don't
know Queen d7 what's the story here how
does V to get defended I'm guessing b3
has to be played soon but Queen B seven
night a for Bishop d7 or I guess on
Queen B seven it's just an immediate b3
in which case I just Castle Bishop d7
the other victor the C file and a have
all my rucks just doing great things
well I don't see what's wrong with it
it's running mate in one and now let's
do it
III our night a four I think it should
be be three here night a four just helps
hmm
it accentuates my own development I get
to develop its tempo
and then they really have to play B form
a knight on a4 is just asking for some
trouble so I don't see any attack
against my king it takes this type of a
advance I believe in order to
successfully get at my king but it feels
like it's two or three tempi too slow
okay so they're going with b3 I should
probably just counsel here no need to
even take that pawn I don't think I
could do without castling here Queen
before into a three in a castle Bishop
d7 rook c8 and think about d5 Bishop b4
huh I guess fr got to go with that pond
advance you make it go bishop DISA and
for Bishop d7 f5 and then just rook c8
ignore this pawn hmm
f4 is the only move I'm thinking about
my knight is then a little bit
vulnerable wonder if I should insert g6
this break hmm might be a fine defensive
move you know III think I see a way
where I could actually devote some
attention
normally playing on making pond moves on
the side where yeah in these in these
opposite side castling cases not only
something to shy away from but I think I
could invest these Tempe and it'll turn
out to be worthwhile as I don't see an
immediate attack it's still gonna take
me some time here Bishop d7 f5 rook F a
g6 concerns me then I think what I want
to be prepared to meet is on an FF six
move Bishop f8 move so I'm not quite
there in time I don't have I'd really
like to have my rook on c8 that's
certainly the more active square can I
really can I get that in because the
other threat is f5 and then f6 on f6 I
want to back up
also g6 is purposeful because it defends
my night I think I should go for that
give some security to my night
make sure the G file does not open up
I'm gonna invest some defensive moves
from my king their Queen gets too crazy
the knight on c3 well I might as well
chalk him up as a bit of a loose piece
as he requires the defence of the Queen
okay I expected and now I guess rook
here actually yeah because my other idea
I want to be able to play here d5
you know let's go here initially I was
thinking rook e8 but why not rook here
so if they play f6 I back up here and we
have a case of some fixed pawns there's
really no getting at my king this move
does not scare me and it normally upon
with such great depth should be a
concern but I don't believe in this case
it is so hmm if white isn't careful like
if this root comes over to the F file
seeing that there's nothing more may be
going on with the G file I might be able
to jump in here and pick up pick off
upon
let's see maybe this rook here my queen
is pressure on e4 I could improve my
queen with this but also I get forked
big time let's not do that could they
think about something here
they probably should cuz mm-hmm yep
okay should I take on v3 right now or
maybe I should get now I'm not going to
do this I want to keep my Queen
defending here and even even this maybe
I should do get my bishop on this
diagonal if this smooth shut down and
I'm fine with coming back yeah I think I
like Bishop FA let's get that in I have
some pretty good coordination very very
important I maintain my pawn here it's
tempting is this well I don't know maybe
some of you viewing this right now might
have played this many times already but
it's weakens d5 and I need to keep that
guy out of there so I think a nice
improvement is here maybe baiting light
some into playing f6 and I'll happily
happily return my queen is maybe a bit
overloaded in a way
I know let's go with this should I take
on b3 first now let's get on the long
diagonal even if the Queen gets here at
some point my king could always kind of
duck get to h8 on this capture I'm not
even sure which way I would wreak no I'm
sure I'm definitely sure which way I'd
recapture with the H pun new square for
my king and I keep defense over e six
what I don't want to have happen is my
rook on f8 enough six because then he's
playing it to AJ and there's no prospect
really for him to activate so on f6 I
want to come out of here so that one day
he can be liberated by way of d5 but a
minute advantage that many moves have
been played by sharp position
okay this Knight is now protected
because they're looking to challenge
this guy
is now the time for takes here hmm I
play a five a four even well they're not
prepared to challenge man let's go with
this no I don't even consider the bishop
moves Oh interesting
hmm oh you know adults I didn't consider
I can maybe take twice here yeah and I
probably should now I give up this
Square to the night but I am winning
upon and maybe I could actually just
work around that night hmm ah let's see
it's not spend too much time here yeah
I'm gonna try to show that I could work
around that night on d5 winding up on
here but let's see I take my bishop what
am I going to do to recapture I would
take with the night
certainly scary a knight on f6 scares me
interesting defensive setup that light
is going with here play Bishop e6 let's
go with the knight
my control over f5 kind of squashes
their influence along the F file from
seeing us from seeing further squares f6
f7 I am up upon but here comes that
night hmm I think I should capture no
let's make sure that B file opens up
yeah I think my attack is coming faster
it's just a check here and there's even
a pawn push I think I'll take let's
let's go with this and break down that
cc2 b3 structure I have a check here I
kind of go to the corner hmmm where else
am I gonna go here takes widths check
right here King in the corner h5 I think
I take with the knight being cut out at
night man hopefully he's a good defender
alright let's let's continue taking if
this Knight goes in that direction it's
one less attacking piece have to worry
about
pretty sure I am faster here I think my
rooks are doing a better job let's see
my queen stopping this check starting to
even out some on the clock if the knight
takes Bishop e6 maybe even Bishop e6
still yeah let's go here yeah definitely
here he takes him out then yeah we
deficit sad effing it Bishop move I'm
almost certain this is the number one
move because it's helping get one more
piece involved soon to have every piece
working except this guy but that's the
one that I want to devote for defense
with my king and once I'm on this file
and I'll be looking for an improving
type move some rook lift mites been
stripped of their defense their pawn
defense for their King Knight f6 I'm
running to the corner I have some pretty
easy follow-up move rook F a so he's
basically all-in I guess they're going
to try for age 5 it's still quite timely
I'm gonna be taking here hit the rook
I'm preparing a bishop move I keep it I
could even allow this one two three it
takes four moves before you're at this
point notice of rook right here would be
mate coupled with that Knight but that's
a lot of Tempe they're down on time now
so I'm looking at rook c8 he's not
needed on the D file anymore
looking just crash through on the beep
on actually how we doing materialized
three four five I'm up upon even okay
let's give this check could even take
here I don't know how and open this up
where is he going
okay that night is a pretty big pest I
must say take here and then rook III and
then here I'm afraid of Queen d4 hmm
just take oh well I could try to get
under the seventh with rook here you
know let's let's hold my ground here
let's let's get active on the seventh
like this maybe King is certainly
walking a tightrope heading towards the
center is he I guess maybe King here are
you gonna do something like night h5 of
King here Knight takes Knight I take air
force the King back I guess and then get
back over here okay there there first
rank is weakened some I missing
something why are they not recapturing
that rook okay
insert the check first I guess our rook
h1 king b2 and then Queen here
their queen is unprotected I'm gonna go
with this and then queen a7 sir Ensor
okay two pins the knight to the Queen my
back rank is vulnerable
yikes
scary let's go here so
rook on h2 but now some heavy piece back
here coupled with that night and I'm
dead
oh they just hung their queen okay just
take their queen and I could drop my
rook back I take the knight if King
takes and just forgot that I was on
their queen there I just devote him to
defense with my back rank even though I
already had my Bishop there for that
nine seconds so maybe they're just
playing on some out of momentum
I guess actually what I should be doing
is just getting rid of this night and
that way there's no back rang stuff
against me I could take there with check
I have this square covered with my
bishop let's just take him out and then
get a flight square here next and then
they're down on time hmm it was quite
some resistance there in that uh
I started to as soon as one work is off
I'm thinking in my have I'm going to be
able to crash through mmm I was really
really tight game I go into the analysis
that was that was a good game in hmm
okay
as mentioned a Sicilian night or f-sharp
position I think I shared everything I
wanted to share during the game um I
think I think I'm okay with actually
going straight in for just checking out
the evaluation this is I'm not so sure
about rook to b8 I guess we'll have a
look at rook to b8 I don't know I think
I think it was an okay played game I'm
not sure
not sure if there are any tactics missed
well I guess we're gonna find out
let's put it on let me just go back to
the start and just kind of get a feel
just doing a quick blunder check here
and the typical slight edge for white d3
let me put the arrows on as well this is
a pretty Universal move King to be one
but anticipating this idea with the rook
on b8 maybe the king is standing better
on c1 it's always a tough call you never
really know for sure where the King
stands best h5 this is something I
pointed out I wanted to kind of stay
away from did not just pop up h5 at one
point this
my fear takes oh ok if i take with the
night then there's g5 and then g6 ok but
i don't have to take with the night ok
but maybe this was even one move sooner
yeah like right here actually this was
this was the first moment where I was
actually thinking about Age 5
now I'm mistaken the first moment I was
thinking about h5 was when g4 was played
why is this not a good idea because of
this capture and if I'm taking here I'm
not threatening to take the night after
g5 take with the night here and then
here so very very important details the
structural change really weakens these
extremely important center squares d5
its structure is undermined now I have
to do what I have to devote a piece to
defending this pawn and that that's an
inconvenience so I want to be careful of
that it was a thought because it looks
too maybe pry open the H file for some
rook activity but it's not quite working
out here okay so I stay clear of this h5
idea instead I went with rook to b8 let
me point out this sacrifice b5 they're
not showing it here but white could go
in for this it's not really working out
why is it not working out because of
this okay so maybe white would first
need let's say a king on b1 before I
would have fear of some P sacrifice on
b5 because in the end I'm getting at
that a to pawn if light goes in for that
sacrifice on b5 okay noted I could have
still played b5 here without Ruby 8
however as played this was not like a
waste of time by any means tied in with
the knight jumping into c4 he was
brought right to life so we got Rick b8
in suggesting Bishop takes Knight you
know I guess this is a pretty big
turning point right around here
suggesting king b1 once more instead of
the bishop move a 95 Bishop takes Bishop
takes g5 f 4 hmm to work around a knight
or not suggesting to work around it Oh
an h4 looking for this notice how white
has
really advanced their kingside and we're
looking at the G file there already have
that direct connection between the rooks
so g6 incoming bishop air versus the
Knights mmm
tough call I don't know okay well Bishop
d3 was played I'm jumping into c4 it
likes but Knight takes bishop oh and
they want to do that it's fine or night
see far it still likes white here
capture it the Queen guess is okay but
it prefers capture I have the V file and
now King b1 I guess this is already very
important moment yeah so this helped me
some it's clocked in at 0 I guess the
idea with King bee one is to vacate c1
for defense of b2 no o Queen c1 is an
option replayed king b1 watch straight
in for g5 I was thinking about h5 I
don't have this square in G v h6 yeah
maybe I certainly wouldn't be playing h6
if I was castled one of the benefits of
keeping the King on his home square is
in well specific cases like this should
g5 happen I could take and now just
claim well
I don't need to castle in order to
activate my rook I already connect I
already have my rook activated
there is still consume consume that
there is that disconnect between the
rucks but when we Castle we look to get
the King safe and get rook activity I at
least have one of the two in this in
this position if there was a g5 push
after capture I castled very late in
this game so we have the B file open up
9 h5 is in and did I organize my piece
as well from this point on I played
first Queen b7 III I know I counseled it
comes out for it wants to go straight in
for d5 and Bishop d7 is another
suggestion not best with g6 but I
thought this was time well spent and I
wants to go with g5 rook there and this
is a move I don't think we can trust the
computer he's a computer evaluation with
this smooth I think it's putting too
much weight on this pawn having great
depth I think that this is fine for
black
it's slowly build out get these moves in
and yeah I don't buy it I don't believe
we could really trust f6 in this
position because it shuts down
completely the Kings side and I have no
fear of let's say the F file opening up
and getting at my king I can always
produce a square for my King on h7 to
fend off against any back ranked mates
so yeah I don't I don't really buy f6
Queen up to was much more human
I'm just reorganizing here my bishop
there yeah and this is the first moment
where I could have captured under five
but I didn't see it
it's forgetting that there's not enough
support for f5 anymore all right you
know what that's probably said wrong I
don't think I ever really yeah I was I
was never even of the mindset to make
captures on a5 primary reason is that I
just see the weaknesses it's it's
creating however right around this point
I can be winning upon with that capture
I didn't see it I went went on with a5
Bishop d4 now I may take now things are
really heating up likes Knight f4 yeah I
guess in a way this was a help capturing
my bishop because I get to reposition my
knight and reinforce f5 think about
jumping into e6
that's it's tough to really work out the
difference differences here
there's Knight f4 Bishop takes Bishop
mm-hmm sharp position and now it's I
guess I'm just getting there first now
they for just a growing advantage from
here on out anything missed mmm-hmm yeah
it's there I guess there's a lot of
different winning ideas this was one of
my concerns mm-hmm and I'm actually a
bit I was seeing things this would I
would this is what I was looking at rook
here and then if I do this I was fearful
of some some of Queen move here getting
at my king I guess I could do whatever
and clearly this is illegal so I could
have gone in for this capture I was
spending quite some time but in the end
I figured just let it sit
rook takes check and then I'm just
trying to make the clean be a queen
really very tough to try and find a
defense here multiple checking moves
rook Queen Queen on a three and got the
pin that they overlooked there maybe
that would have been a fine defensive
move I don't know the night here
well no I'm on the rook as well and I
guess it's just nothing they could do at
that point
so where is really the improvement I
guess it's really from the g5 shy away
from g5 here King b1 might be a tough
move to go with but it allows for this
idea maybe even the Queen moving and
devoting a minor piece to defending b2
keeping the structure still keeping the
structure at home I know no sharp game
out of the Sicilian I door
more more to say yeah I don't know tough
game
feel free as usual in the comment
section below to leave any feedback to
this video and as usual I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care bye
you